is the setup and the diagram is really
just to give you a bit of a nudge if you
did enjoy this is one of the few
questions with maybe you could get away
with doing the question without at this
diagram
you've given two complex numbers
7w you're told that the area of the
triangle traced out by z 2w with the
origin is capital a the area and then
they asked you to prove this we'd result
what you're required to prove is that or
there's an extra zero times the country
of W minus W times the country of Z is
that whatever that has to do with
anything okay
now I kind of like to think I've
mentioned this before that sometimes
questions in extension to are hard just
because they are the intimidating okay
you look at you all right but down it's
alright this can be done if you're
patient with it and if you just speaks
you the information god okay
for instance the first thing I notice in
that they tell me the area of the
triangle is a and that appears in this
result that I'm going to head toward
okay does that make sense so the first
thing I'm going to do because it's
actually quite easy you can do it as a
two unit student the first thing I'm
going to do is work out what the area of
this triangle is okay now we know
basically two ways to work out the area
we're trying one of the two ways
the the u7 way of learning it's just the
formula which is 1/2 base times height
right base meeting in either size and
height meeting like what height
we're being perpendicular height so you
have a look at this diagram and do have
the perpendicular height anywhere the
answer is no okay so I probably not
going to go in that direction that leads
to the other way of finding the area of
triangle which is I would usually would
get half a B sciency I mean you could
use the cosine of cosine x z here but
that's a bit of a long way around
I'm gonna go for half a B side see now
have a look if I say a and B those are
two legs of the triangle okay now you've
got three one two three all the three
which to do you think I've been easiest
to get you to access what do you reckon
yeah I think the ones from the origin to
Zed the origin to W I mean I guess we
could work at this one but it's going to
be more complicated it involves both of
these numbers whereas finding these two
you come to the origin that's really
easy okay something right huh eh it
doesn't matter which ones which a will
be right we'll call this one over here a
right so by definition the length of
this side is Bawdsey right or the
absolute value of zip right so I'm just
gonna say that's a if this one ducky is
B then I'm gonna say that length is tell
you the modulus okay now the last piece
is scientist E right and in quantity a
scientist C like which and who is it is
that when you've got the two sides the
area you're interested in is the
included angle right the one in between
so in this case it's this angle in here
right what's the value of the single
yeah good it's the difference between
theta and the five so I've got sign and
then the particular value see I'm after
is the one is fine okay now I guess I
could play around with that a little
wall but for now let me just keep it up
in the back
because when you know whenever you've
got any kind of new required to prove
result right you've got to know where
you're going right this is one of the
reasons why in a trig identity proof
it's like okay we lay out for you what
you're supposed to get to because the
way you've manipulate one of these signs
is based on where are you headed right I
mean I guess I could have started doing
this but without knowing this is where
I'm going right now we're ready to
actually sit out this proof okay so I'm
going to have to look at either this
side or this side I want to manipulate
one of them to get to the other which
one would you like me to start
I'd probably go through the left-hand
side right you could go for them right
but generally I mean that looks sort of
simplified whereas this is like a mess
of different things that I guess are
going to combine together collect like
terms all that sort of thing okay so Zed
W could you get it - W okay let's have a
look at this left-hand side okay now we
know the context that was can be
represented in what two ways and they
haven't given us a way yet the question
hasn't said it this way or that way so
you get to choose so which of the two
ways again
you've got rectangular form which is X
plus iy and then you've got Paula form
which is closely there's most likely
them now as soon as you save over the
both out loud it sort of tells you which
direction you want to go into which one
would you choose clearly you should go
for Paula for what's the big clue to
what I've got on the board already that
tells me follow me okay yeah look this
is where I'm headed remember right and
it's got slides in it and it's got this
is not this is the are at the front of
our Paula form right it's the modulus of
another so polymers a clear choice right
so how am I going to write a number like
say said how am I gonna write back Paula
for just write general polar form up
here this is how we would normally write
powerful
okaywe honestly so what zip how do I
write back yeah yeah good cool there's
it so far so good
how would I write W Bob the clinic
mm-hmm what's the butchers of good it's
still more dummy isn't it
but will you take the conjugate you
don't change how far it is you treat it
from being facing up to facing down yes
so I guess what W would be some way down
feel so okay what's going to happen over
here okay so the the what the argument
Allah has gone down it's going clockwise
instead of a eg clockwise so therefore
this is going to be negative fine
and this is also going to be negative
that's it so it's a bit of a long best
but that is Zed Zed there and don't move
ah in fact maybe just for yourself
because there's gonna be a lot of stuff
on this slide maybe you're on the label
for yourself what's one okay okay I've
only done one half of this line but
that's a KP patient read it again it
looks intimidating but just because it's
long to write let's write the next book
okay
well we get to W we already know how to
write W because there's dunbar so it's
got the same watch Alice and what's the
angle it's just fine it's just fine to
get to W so fine
like that and then I come to the lusts
of my complex numbers on the 4 z bar
right so then one dose is still ones in
like that and what's the ugly gonna be
this time no you okay I'll let me again
label that so you could see what's what
okay now we've found a substitution it
looks awful but that's as bad as it's
good to get everything from here we can
simplify okay